what started as a way for creations to
increase their bottom line has expanded
into a consumer service as well you can
get someone to buy your groceries mrs.
Freeman or even hang out with your mom
Jenna can't make it safe but I'll be
hanging out with you oh don't judge
people love you mom and even break up
with your boyfriend for you hi I'm Bob
from dr. break-up Jena Friedman says
really nice but she just wants to be
friends great day she will get with me
best 30 dollars I've ever spent when it
comes to providing outsourced labor
India is king with a large English
speaking workforce willing to work for
significantly lower wages than the
average American in 2015
India's outsourcing industry was worth a
hundred and forty six billion US dollars
with about ten million people employed
in the IT industry alone
[Music]